oh nah what's what's the green god name
oh they got involved nope nope the other
one
frankenstein
[Music]
i do the segment with everybody where we
play a game called heads up oh yeah
have you played before i played before
yeah
have you ever played that yeah
what is it so you're trying to get me to
guess like
the word that comes on the screen okay
okay
oh don't give me the word
no they're not hard they're not hard the
first category
is basketball okay okay i'm closing my
eyes so i can't cheat okay
go
i can't say the words in that right no
[Music]
it's timed you guys yeah i know i know i
know
they may need up to portland
trailblazers
yes this happens to me a lot of the
pick-and-roll two people
now no two people coming at me
double-teamed yup yup yup uh
intermission
half time teams go to the locker room
half time yeah
uh janice score all his points there
milwaukee box no he scores all his
points in this place
on the court oh the paint yep you got it
best dunker of all time best known for
all time dominick wilkins no no no no no
best dunker best dunker
ah vince carter
[Music]
this car
dominique wilkins um this dude wears
glasses
they they got like their own game they'd
be flying
they'd be flying you got it harry potter
goblin fire harry potter sweatshirt
stone harry potter champion
that one that one he's the dad of uh
dragon
a lucius malfoy yes oh uh you get a car
you get a car you get a car oprah
winfrey
shaq charles barkley
uh inside the community it's a tv uh
yeah uh forehead and cleans everything
it's a brand well you can't say clean is
it mr clean
yes
[Music]
yes this guy is all wrapped up they dead
they all rap
oh whoever throws the pass whoever
passes the ball quarterback
yes in the clutch you got the final one
thank you for indulging me
that was great it was ellen page yeah
ellen page is an actress you know the
only ellen i know it's the generator